aujourd'hui je veux qu'on se parle des
smartphones qui vont arriver l'année
prochaine regardez je fais une
installation et je vous parle en même
temps comme ça on fait tout comme ça
comment ça va est-ce que ça va c'est
vrai que là c'est la fin de l'année fin
2022 noms de Dieu qu'est-ce que c'est
passé vite et 2023 ce profil avec des
choses extrêmement intéressantes avec
plein de nouveautés smartphone donc on a
déjà vu des smartphones qui vont arriver
l'année prochaine je sais pas si vous
avez regardé sur ma chaîne mais il y a
plein de trucs qui vont arriver que j'ai
déjà pu prendre en main que je vous ai
déjà présenté et ça ne va pas s'arrêter
là d'ailleurs plein de surprises vous
allez voir ça va être super cool je
voulais faire un petit récap avec vous
pour voir ce qui va arriver l'année
prochaine vous allez voir nom de Zeus
j'ai noté plein de choses là-dessus
alors je me suis basé sur ce que je
connais les produits qui ont été
annoncés sur ce que j'ai pu prendre en
main déjà ça arrive ça commence c'est
cool sur les différentes rumeurs vous
allez voir je vais vous montrer plein
d'images ce qui va arriver et ce qu'on
croit deviner quand on sent un peu la
tendance et je pense franchement que
2023 va être un grand cru
2022 2022 ça a été cool il y a eu
vachement de produits plein de
nouveautés d'ailleurs avant toute chose
avant de commencer prenez deux secondes
pour me dire quel était le smartphone
que vous avez préféré en 2022 vraiment
alors je voulais pas forcément acheter
soyons clairs mais quel est le produit
qui vous êtes titiller votre curiosité
qui vous a donné envie peut-être
l'avez-vous peut-être avez-vous pas et
dites-moi avant même qu'on avance dans
cette vidéo quel produit vous pensez qui
va vous plaire le plus en 2023
dites-le-moi j'ai hâte de vous lire donc
allez-y dans les commentaires allez-y
alors moi je vous ai regardé plein plein
de trucs vous savez il y a eu de très
belles évolutions on l'a vu cette année
avec plein d'annonces autour des
smartphones qui se plient et je pense
que l'année prochaine ça va vraiment
être 2023 l'année de la démocratisation
du smartphone pliant ce pliable comme
vous voulez bref plus en plus parce que
et si vous regardez il y a pas longtemps
je vous ai montré plusieurs smartphones
qui SPIE le premier alors je vous l'ai
montré je l'ai pas pris en mains
celui-là mais j'ai fait une vidéo pour
vous en parler parce que je le trouve
Dingo c'est le oppo fine and the flip en
fait au pot il nous avait montré en
début d'année le find N qui était un
smartphone qui se plie un peu comme le
même format que le Galaxy Z fold de
Samsung c'est à dire vous l'ouvrez vous
avez un plus grand écran donc ça il
l'avait présenté ce format là je l'avais
montré en début d'année puis je trouvais
cool j'adorais ce format on sentait
quasiment pas la plus haut c'était cool
et là ils ont montré dans les
inondations là où ils montrent vraiment
les grosses innovations qui vont arriver
puis tout le travail de R&D qui font des
choses sortiront peut-être pas mais en
tout cas il montre et donc ils ont
montré deux nouveaux smartphones pliants
ils ont montré le find alors attendez
oppo finden 2 donc celui c'est le même
format que le finden et ils ont montré
le finden de flip et celui-là il est
cool pourquoi parce qu'il reprend
exactement les codes du Galaxy Z flip 4
de Samsung donc c'est chouette et
surtout il y a un très grand écran
extérieur je trouve ça hyper canon donc
ce qui est sûr c'est annoncé ce
smartphone va arriver au premier
trimestre 2023 en France on va donc
pouvoir la voir pouvoir l'acheter
j'imagine que oppo va nous proposer un
tarif j'espère qu'il va être assez
maîtrisé on verra je pense le même prix
que ce que vous propose un Samsung sur
un format équivalent donc ça va être
vraiment super cool donc j'ai vraiment
hâte de la voir le tester de le prendre
en main et je pense que ce smartphone là
ça va être un carton plein donc ça c'est
chouette ensuite vous avez présenté
d'autres produits je vous ai présenté
souvenez-vous il y a pas longtemps le
Honor Magic vs on se parle ici d'un
smartphone qui se plie de Honor on se
parle d'un smartphone qui est super
classe qui est super beau très belle
finition signée au nord et la bonne
nouvelle c'est que ce smartphone va
également arriver probablement au mois
de février 2023 donc c'est quelque chose
qu'on va arriver au début de l'année
2023 il sera commercialisé en France
alors pour autant bien évidemment soyons
clairs je ne pense pas que ce smartphone
se vende en très grande quantité mais
vous savez le but pour une marque comme
Honor qui s'est séparé de Huawei il y a
quelques temps il y a un an et demi
aujourd'hui et bien ils sont là pour
donner encore plus de crédibilité à la
marque et ça passe bien évidemment par
des innovations par la technologie on
l'a vu avec le Magic 4 pro cette année
notamment et il le montre avec la
maîtrise du client donc bien évidemment
même s'ils savent que ce smartphone ils
vont pas vendre énormément pour autant
il montre l'INO la techno et la solidité
de la marque donc ça ça va être très
très chouette donc on verra ce
smartphone et potentiellement si vous
intéresse vous allez pouvoir l'acheter
l'année prochaine j'ai une lumière qui
m'a lâché derrière voilà donc on va
faire un changement de lumière mettre
celle-là c'est toujours mieux voilà
j'aime quand les lumières me lâche c'est
très joli ce petit truc hein d'aputure
ces petits éclairages ils sont top mais
bon la batterie des fois on s'en fout
continuons alors un autre truc que j'ai
vu aussi qui est très cool c'est le
Xiaomi alors Xiaomi le mix fold de 2
alors le mix fold 2 il est pas prévu
d'arriver en France c'est pareil on est
sur le même format que Honor avec
quelques petites différences mais c'est
sens ça raconte sensiblement la même
histoire alors il va pas arriver je
pense pas qu'il arrive pourquoi déjà il
y a plusieurs raisons il y a toujours on
va deux principales la première c'est
que Xiaomi je pense pas qu'ils en ont
des caisses non plus comme au nord ils
ont toujours aussi un besoin de
crédibiliser la marque montrer qu'ils
sont bons dans l'innovation d'ailleurs
on l'a vu avec le Xiaomi 12 Xiaomi 12
Pro ils sont super super innovations les
smartphones sont hyper crédibles mais
c'est pas les smartphones qui vont le
plus qui vont le plus Yomi c'est du
milieu et de l'entrée de gamme c'est là
où ils font vraiment du volume et de la
rasia il y avait rien mis c'est la folie
d'ailleurs ça pourrait être un vieux
slogan des 80 avec réduit c'est la folie
bref donc mais je pense pas qu'ils ont
toujours dur peut-être est-ce qu'ils
vont le mettre au catalogue de leur site
internet pour ne pas avoir à payer ça
coûte cher si vous voulez mettre un
smartphone dans la distribution il faut
déjà qu'il y ait des distributeurs dans
les magasins notamment voyez Fnac Darty
boulanger et qu'on sort alors vous allez
différents niveaux distribution on va
faire très très rapidement en fait c'est
distributeurs quand ils croient vraiment
un produit ils le prennent et ils le
mettent en rayon donc vous le voyez dans
votre magasin parce qu'ils savent que
vous savez quand ils prennent un peu de
place dans un magasin chaque espace doit
être rentabilisé donc si mettre le
smartphone ce qui savent qu'ils vont le
vendre s'ils ont un peu plus de doute
qu'ils veulent tester le marché avec ça
leur plaît bien et bien il le mette en
ligne donc vous avez les exclusivités
ouais mais ouais c'est toujours un peu
sexy en réalité ça veut dire que ils y
croient mais pas assez pour le mettre en
magasin qui sont pas sur le moment de
vaisseau donc il veut vous le mettre
directement sur leur site web il prend
un peu moins de risques il le stocke
quelque part ça coûte un peu d'argent
mais un petit peu moins donc bon ok ils
font ça et puis lorsqu'une marque veut
tester un peu et pas sûr ou alors
contribué le vraiment garder de la
marche elle le vend directement sur son
site web il y en a qui font ça
d'ailleurs Xiaomi le fait ils vous font
des trucs où vous avez d'abord certains
modèles ou certaines références ou des
fois carrément au début vendu uniquement
sur leur site web et après ça arrive
chez les distributeurs comme ça ça leur
permet d'avoir les marges au début de ne
pas avoir à payer les distributeurs et
puis surtout quand ils veulent tester
des produits ils sont pas sûrs des
quantités comme ça sécurise un petit peu
plus l'histoire donc peut-être qu'on
verra arriver chez Xiaomi un mix fold 2
sur leur catalogue en ligne je crois
convaincu mais peut-être allez savoir en
tout cas c'est chouette enfin il a pris
il y en a plein d'autres on sait qu'il y
a Google qui va arriver avec son pixel
fold en tout cas c'est dans les rumeurs
on en parle donc j'y crois c'est est-ce
que ça arrivera en France ça me
paraîtrait pas déconnant 2023 je sais
pas mais en tout cas ça pourrait arriver
vivons également propose des smartphones
pliants je suis pas convaincu non plus
que ça arrive en France quant à Apple
est-ce qu'ils vont bouger avec un
scrofen qui se plie oui un jour 2023 j'y
crois pas du tout 2025 peut-être je
crois davantage sur 2025 ça me paraît
loin mais vous savez ils prennent le
temps de faire les choses ils vont
tester le marché voir comment ça se
comporte et puis ensuite ils ont j'y
crois vraiment pas pour maintenant on
verra ce me tromper mais on verra et on
verra arriver bien évidemment cette
année 5 Galaxy Z flip 5 j'espère que
d'ailleurs le zflip 5 va mieux utiliser
la place disponible sur l'extérieur de
son smartphone pour vous proposer comme
le propose ici au pot un plus grand
écran externe avec plus d'usage on verra
ça m'intéresse on regardera ça vous
voyez déjà qu'au niveau de la
technologie au niveau du pliable il y a
vachement de choses qui vont arriver
c'est super intéressant alors ça c'est
que le pliable il y a d'autres choses
qui vont arriver on va se parler déjà
d'un produit qui va être le plus attendu
alors c'est pas forcément le produit qui
va le plus loin le meilleur le plus
Dingo mais c'est le plus équilibré en
tout cas un produit qui est extrêmement
bien équilibré qui est hyper canon et
qui donne un peu les tendances c'est
sans les iPhone et l'iPhone 15 va
arriver au deuxième semestre 2023 mais
regardez déjà parce que c'est vraiment
le sujet qui intéresse qu'est-ce que va
proposer Apple alors a priori il
pourrait y avoir une évolution dans la
gamme alors vous le savez cette année on
a eu l'iPhone 14 et le 14 plus première
fois qui arrive un modèle plus là dans
cette ce nouveau design c'était plutôt
cool l'iPhone 14 pro les 114 pro max on
pourrait voir arriver un iPhone 15
ultra potentiellement qui viendrait
remplacer l'iPhone 14 pro donc on aurait
peut-être pas j'ai pas vraiment des
guillemets c'est très très loin pour le
dire mais c'est ce que j'ai vu en
chinant à droite à gauche peut-être
qu'on aurait pas d'iPhone 15 pro max
mais on aurait peut-être potentiellement
aller savoir un iPhone 15 ultra on
continuerait à monter dans
le pré là où la différence entre
l'iPhone 14 pro et l'iPhone 14 pro max
ça va être une différence de de format
parce que sous le capot c'est quasiment
la même chose donc bien évidemment là on
verrait une prémiumisation encore
supplémentaire pour
regonfler marge et pour continuer à
placer la marque encore plus dans le
Premium donc là vous avez déjà une gamme
entre d'un côté le modèle normal 14 14 +
c'est vraiment la même chose c'est juste
la taille qui va changer le format qui
va changer vous auriez un pro au-dessus
donc on aurait un 15 plus ça serait à
peu près la même chose 15 pro et 15
ultra qui serait encore au dessus donc
là imaginez un smartphone de base à mon
avis à 1700 balles de 1000 balles on va
continuer à aller dans la premiumisation
alors est-ce tarif là qu'est-ce qui est
vend nous proposer ça va être compliqué
de l'imaginer mais en tout cas ça
pourrait être cool alors est-ce qu'il
continuerait avec une différence de
génération de puce bon il y a un moment
ça me semble compliqué de sortir la puce
de 2024 dans un smartphone de 2023 il y
a un moment il y a un peu des limites
vous voyez est-ce qu'ils vont intégrer
une puce gravée en trois nanomètres par
TSMC versus une 4 nanomètres j'en sais
rien ça ça me paraîtrait surprenant mais
bon en tout cas il pourrait y avoir ça
ça pourrait être cool au sujet qui est
intéressant chez Apple c'est l'arrivée
de l'usb-c ça c'est pour être en
conformité avec la législation
européenne excite le port Lightning on a
de l'usb-c qui arrivera alors il y a des
rumeurs qui font état que Apple pourrait
ne mettre que de la recharge par in j'y
crois pas un instant je pense pas
aujourd'hui en tout cas peut-être demain
attention c'est dans les tuyaux j'y
crois mais pas pour 2023 peut-être 2024
2025 allez savoir on sait pas du tout ça
me paraît pas pour tout de suite par
contre ce qui pourra arriver tout de
suite c'est la fin de la carte nano SIM
ils l'ont fait aux États-Unis
aujourd'hui si vous allez aux US si vous
voulez acheter un iPhone vous pouvez pas
avoir de carte SIM à intégrer à
l'intérieur c'est tout là ici donc
est-ce que là ici mais totalement prête
sur le marché français peut-être pas ça
vraiment être ça je parle français mais
je parle Europe en fait si tous les
opérateurs sont prêts pour avoir que de
la sing full SIM Apple fera ça alors
coûtera moins cher de mettre de la SIM
que de venir rajouter une petite découpe
pour avoir une carte nano SIM ça permet
de gagner un petit peu en marche donc ça
peut être aussi intéressant on pourra
arriver avec un zoom optique x 10 en
photo ça pourrait être cool on resterait
bien évidemment sur un carreau dessus
mégapixel tel que sur le ultra nous
mettre un 108 mégapixels je peux pas ça
me paraît très surprenant bon bref donc
voilà ce qui va arriver voilà ce qui
pourrait arriver du côté des iPhone 15
deuxième semestre 2023 on a encore le
temps on en reparlera bien évidemment
sur Youtube donc pensez à vous abonner
c'est pas déjà fait vous cliquez sur le
petit bouton rouge s'il est rouge c'est
que vous n'êtes pas abonné puis surtout
si vous êtes abonné pensez à actionner
la cloche pour être notifié dès que la
prochaine vidéo au revoir et ça croyez
moi c'est très chouette alors on produit
qu'on attend énormément ce sont les
Samsung Galaxy S23 S23 S23 plus S23
ultra c'est smartphone pour être annoncé
le premier février
nous vient de Ice Universe sur Twitter
mais bon en règle générale c'est quand
même ce qu'il dit donc le premier
février on aurait le pack pour ça que
des pincettes mais ça ça pourrait être
cool parce que on verra arriver alors
regardez il y a des petites infos là on
aurait des rendus des smartphones on
voit ici le S23 S23 plus S23 ultra ce
qui est très cool c'est qu'en fait
l'année dernière il y avait une
différence de design entre les S22 S2 de
plus qui tape le même design et le S22
ultra qui est un peu différent qui
ressemblait vraiment à ça et enfin ce
qui est très très drôle est-ce que
j'aime bien c'est qu'en fait ils vont
reprendre les codes du S22 ultra donc on
aurait à peu près le même design au
niveau du dos donc c'est chouette alors
on regarde l'idée de ce qu'on avait
l'année dernière mais on va retravailler
un peu tout ça avec des smartphones qui
seraient un peu plus arrondis sur les
coins sur les s2323+ et un poil plus
carré avec un écran incurvé sur le S23
ultra vous voyez les images donc hop ça
c'est rigolo ça c'est marrant donc à
voir ça sera un petit bouton là et puis
là on aurait un capteur d'empreinte
digitale je sais pas est-ce que ça sera
un bouton pour Bixby j'en sais rien
allez savoir en tout cas voilà à quoi ça
pourrait ressembler alors bien
évidemment la confirmation d'avoir ici
un S Pen bien évidemment parce que le
modèle pas vient remplacer le note la
gamme note qui a dépéri un qui a disparu
donc ça c'est assez marrant et puis
alors regardez on a d'autres rendus ici
au niveau du S23
ultra donc on aurait cette petite photo
là voilà il y en a qu'une seule ici et
on aurait un bout de spec qui nous dit
qu'en fait sur la caméra de selfie on
aurait pas une 40 mégapixels on aurait
eu 12 mégapixels on aurait on est
guillemets hein on y va avec des
pincettes mais en tout cas ça sera assez
cool et là on a des petits rendus donc
du S23 ultra voilà ça pourrait
ressembler à ça ok c'est mignon tu en
reste vraiment dans ce qu'on a avec
ultra ceux qui vont plus changer
potentiellement ça serait allé S23 il y
a 23 plus avec ce design un peu
différent je trouve très joli en noir
c'est sobre c'est simple c'est très très
élégant donc bon une fois de plus on
prend ça avec des pincettes il y a
peut-être du branding si ça ressemble à
ça qui arriverait dessus mais je trouve
ça assez joli donc ça ça me plaît bien
ça c'est cool d'autant plus qu'a été
confirmé et bien que là-dessus on aurait
pas de processeur exinos donc vous savez
avec les smartphones très haut de gamme
de Samsung sur les gammes s on avait
d'un côté pour l'Europe et le reste du
monde je vais dire les processeurs
exinos de Samsung et puis on avait pour
les États-Unis et le Canada le
processeur de Welcome le plus performant
donc il y a une la différence entre un
film qui se faisait en termes de
performance même s'il existe allait bien
mais c'est pas là on avait le plus loin
et quand on met 1000 balles ou presque
1000 balles dans un téléphone on veut
pouvoir effectivement avoir ce qui se
fait mieux et là cette année on aura
partout sur tous les produits dans le
monde entier je fais bien le monde
entier on aura des Snapdragon 8 Jane II
et ça ça me plaît et ça c'est cool alors
il y a un autre produit qui est un peu
attendu que j'attends de voir c'est le
oneplus 11 alors on a un rendu le ce à
quoi il pourrait ressembler alors on va
toujours marquer un seul Blade le
partenariat avec un seul Blade vous
savez oppo oneplus le même groupe même
si c'est son 2 marques qui sont
travaillées complètement différemment le
partenariat seul Blade a été emmené par
oneplus et oppo qu'il l'a également donc
ça c'est cool j'avais été un peu déçu on
va parler oneplus 10 pro très
honnêtement cette année je l'ai trouvé
un moyen moins bien que le 9 pro sur la
photo donc on va voir si avec le 11 pro
ils arrivent un petit peu à réhausser un
peu l'histoire et être un peu plus sexy
j'aimerais vraiment parce que
franchement c'est une très jolie marque
oneplus même si c'est vrai qu'ils sont
un peu plus en difficulté ça reste
toujours une très jolie marque donc on
va voir ce qui arrive là-dessus autre
produit que je vous ai présenté l'autre
jour alors j'avais pas le produit mais
je voulais montrer parce qu'elle était
annoncé en Chine c'est le chien mit 13
et le Xiaomi 13 il est cool pourquoi
parce que vous savez qu'en fait qui se
passe c'est que Xiaomi avec le premier à
dégainer donc qu'est-ce que fait chier
homme ici c'est à dire qu'il l'annonce
d'abord en Chine donc il a été présenté
en Chine ce Xiaomi 13 donc on sait tout
hein allez voir ma vidéo sur le Xiaomi
13 comme ça vous saurez tout absolument
tout et il va arriver avec un petit
décalage en France ça permet à le
premier à dire on est le premier
smartphone intégré le stade dragon 8
Jane II c'est nous number one on est les
premiers tac tac tac on y va c'est parti
et pour autant les autres vont arriver
dans la foulée bon ça change pas
vraiment grand chose parce que chez nous
il devrait arriver potentiellement au
mois de février pour l'instant il y a
pas de confirmation de la part de Xiaomi
France là dessus mais en tout cas il va
arriver ça c'est chouette alors un autre
produit que j'attends énormément qui est
mon smartphone coup de cœur de l'année
2022 d'ailleurs je vais regarder quand
la vidéo sera finie elle sera en ligne
que vous aurez tous commenté vous allez
avoir qu'elles ont été votre coup de
cœur de 2022 mon smartphone coup de cœur
l'année 2022 c'était le oppo finding 5
Pro j'ai adoré sur tout au niveau de la
photo même si tu es loin d'être parfait
au niveau du téléobjectif il y a des
choses un petit peu reprendre mais tu es
super cool il y avait de très très
jolies rendus photo j'adorais ce
smartphone et du coup j'attends vraiment
de voir ce que va nous proposer au pot
sur le finding 6 pro alors là j'ai des
petits rendus potentiels pour essayer de
voir un peu à quoi ça pourrait
ressembler au niveau du find x 6 alors
on d'un côté un truc un petit peu rond
un peu comme le oneplus vous voyez en
déporté plus au centre et lui One Piece
ce serait plus sur le côté donc on me
met ça donc là on pourra avoir
effectivement un zoom périscopique ici
grand angle ultra grand-angle qui flashe
ici avec assalblade donc ça
potentiellement ça serait ça et l'autre
côté on me met un rendu presse un peu
plus carré alors on reprend toujours la
même idée c'est à dire grand-angle ultra
grand-angle le double flashlight qui
vient là et là un zoom périscopique et
un seul Blade toujours donc ça c'est un
peu son tourné à peu près sûr on prend
des pincettes une fois de plus parce que
j'en sais foutrement rien mais c'est ce
qui ressemble en tout cas arriver donc
j'ai vraiment hâte de voir ça d'autant
plus que on aura toujours le processeur
d'image je pense la Marie c'est l'icône
x qu'on a eu l'année dernière avec le
modèle Pro ça c'est super cool et puis
la Marie silicone y qui va arriver
également pour l'audio je pense qu'il
sera intégré dans ce smartphone ça
paraît normal qui était présenté par
oppo directement aux Inno days donc je
pense qu'on va avoir un super smartphone
au niveau de l'image au niveau de la
photo au niveau de l'audio il y a des
promesses qui sont là si elles sont
tenues je vous raconte pas ça va
déchirer aussi donc on regardera ça on
devait 23 il croyez-moi ça va être super
intéressant autre produit j'attends
c'est un cheval qui va arriver le
Samsung Galaxy le S22 fe le S un feu on
l'a vu début fin 2022 fin 2021 pardon je
crois au début 2022 je sais plus moi
j'avais fait une petite vidéo dessus
c'était elle était présente et si si il
a été présenté tout fin 2021 je vous ai
fait une vidéo dessus début 2022 et le
s22fe pour l'instant j'en ai noz donc
j'espère qu'il va arriver parce que
c'est vraiment un smartphone qui était
bien positionné super cool autre produit
que j'attends c'est
qui est le milieu de gamme qui est je
pense en tout cas selon le plus et qui
est une valeur sûre et quand on veut
acheter un smartphone qui rassure un
tarif plutôt maîtrisé on va là-dessus
Galaxy a53 Galaxy 54 pour être aussi un
carton plein alors il y a une autre
marque que j'avais trouvé super
intéressant je voulais pas tout à
l'heure c'est au nord du côté de
l'innovation parce qu'ils ont vachement
Dino du côté matériel du côté logiciel
je vous le redis une fois de plus c'est
tout l'héritage de Huawei qu'on veut
retrouver ici donc je serai pas surpris
de voir arriver un Magic 5 Pro hyper
boosté avec de très belles performances
avec de très belles innovations ça c'est
un truc que j'ai vraiment hâte de voir
parce que je vois beaucoup les équipes
de Honor on a beaucoup discuté sur les
produits sur l'évolution de la marque
c'est intéressant et on voit qu'ils ont
vraiment une force de frappe qui est là
et à mon avis ils sont qu'au début donc
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont vous sortir en
2023 je pense vraiment que sur le Magic
5 Pro au niveau de la photo ils vont
faire un focus monstrueux pour se mettre
déjà au niveau de l'autre ils étaient
parce que le Magic capote est magnifique
en photo il y a de très très beaux
rendus mais je pense qu'ils vont passer
au niveau supérieur donc ça on le
verrait l'année prochaine et ça j'ai
vraiment hâte également autre smartphone
qui me donne vraiment envie que
j'attends c'est le Google pixel 8 le
pixel 6 l'avait trouvé cool mais vous
avez des fois un peu trop long au niveau
soft tout avec le pixel 7 ils ont mieux
moduler tout ça alors il y a beaucoup
derrière d'intelligence artificielle
c'est de la photographie
consultationnelle bon c'est pas mal
enfin c'est même très bien ça marche
très bien pas que ce soit un peu tout
moche pas que ça aille trop loin mais je
trouve qu'avec le pixel c'est cool donc
le pixel 8 smartphone qui va être aussi
extrêmement fort j'ai vraiment hâte de
voir arriver et puis le pixel 7a qui
pourrait potentiellement arriver aussi
mai juin je crois plutôt au mois de juin
qui serait très très cool sans oublier
la première tablette qui va arriver de
Google alors c'est Google ils aiment pas
faire les choses comme tout le monde ils
ont leur écosystème la tablette qu'on
pourra venir poser ça vous fera comme
espèce de nest up max géant ça pourrait
être très cool donc ça j'ai vraiment
hâte aussi de venir voir parce que moi
je suis un très gros client d'une
estomax que j'ai à la maison donc si je
peux le remplacer par une espèce de
nestomac tablette ça me plairait
beaucoup donc ça ça serait super
chouette donc on verra si ça va arriver
effectivement l'année prochaine au
smartphone que j'aime bien j'attends
pour le gaming c'est le rock Phone 7 Pro
rockfone 6 pro c'est toujours une valeur
sûre si on veut faire du gaming sur
smartphone alors le petit sujet là
dessus c'est alors c'est extrêmement
performant ne bougeons par exemple
toujours très très bon mais ils sont pas
au top au niveau de la photo Asus est-ce
qu'ils vont améliorer leur copie au
niveau de la photo pour que journée un
smartphone de gaming qui soit aussi
digne d'être un photophone ce sera un
peu le sujet je pense sur le rockfoncel
pro on verra si ça va arriver on va voir
également l'année prochaine est-ce que
redmi va réussir à continuer à s'imposer
par rapport à Xiaomi pas évident parce
que Xiaomi ils ont beaucoup aussi qui
est là pour le gaming à Remy qui se bat
enfin il y a tout un une vraie bagarre
là-dessus en fait donc on va voir ce
qu'il va arriver Motorola également avec
la partie photo qui est toujours des
fois un peu à la traîne j'aime bien leur
smartphone ils sont jolis un super
design il y a une vraie histoire
derrière la marque mais la photo c'est
toujours un peu le le parent port alors
il y a des choses qui sont bah voilà
mais il faut vraiment l'améliorer donc
s'ils arrivent à l'améliorer je pense
que la marque elle va monter d'un cran
et ça va être cool également vivant vivo
vivo en réalité vu partout sur la Coupe
du Monde vivo vivo vivo de tous les
côtés vivo ils sont super forts
notamment vivants pour vous montrer
toutes l'innovation c'est eux qui ont
créé le capteur d'empreinte digitale
sous l'écran ils sont moteurs dans plein
de technologie comme ça qu'on a un peu
partout et qui viennent de chez vivo
donc ça c'est vachement chouette donc
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont nous sortir
l'année prochaine j'ai hâte de voir je
pense d'ailleurs aussi des choses qui
vont être un peu fortes Microsoft est-ce
qu'ils vont continuer avec la surface du
haut surface du qui est sorti l'année
dernière qui était bon moi je trouve ça
marrant j'aime bien les Inno mais c'est
pas forcément les choses qui vont se
vendre le plus est-ce qu'ils vont
arrêter est-ce qu'ils vont continuer ce
qu'ils vont sortir une surface duo 3
allez savoir autre chose cette année on
a vu arriver pour la première fois une
nouvelle marque le nothing phone one
j'ai bien aimé ce smartphone plutôt
placé dans le haut du milieu de gamme
bon on va dire haut de gamme mais c'est
pas ultra premium qui très très cool
avec une nouvelle histoire un truc un
peu différent j'ai bien aimé je pense
que
que peut
le régulièrement alors se sentiront le
nothing phone 2 fatalement cette année
j'imagine que oui est-ce qu'ils vont
sortir d'autres smartphones un peu plus
milieu de gamme pour venir et choper un
peu le milieu de gamme essayer de choper
un peu de volume pour gagner de l'argent
j'en sais rien en tout cas ça me
paraîtra le bon truc donc j'attends que
ça t'aille peut-être j'espère donc un
autre signe phone 2 pour moi c'est sûr
et peut-être aller savoir un autre
smartphone alors après le problème c'est
que c'est une marque qui est jaune
fabriqué des smartphones concevoir des
smartphones et pouvoir travailler ça
coûte extrêmement cher et ce
qu'aujourd'hui ils ont les moyens
d'avoir différentes références alors
comme c'est des anciennes oneplus est-ce
qu'ils veulent faire comme oneplus un
smartphone à l'année et puis tout un
écosystème qui va se créer on voit il y
a des écouteurs est-ce qu'ils vont aller
vraiment dans la notion d'écosystème
est-ce qu'on peut aller là-dessus il va
y avoir de l'écosystème c'est sûr et
certain est-ce qu'il va y avoir deux
smartphones je parie cette année qui
aura deux smartphones de Nothing je
parie allez on prend le Paris on verra à
la fin de l'année si j'ai gagné si j'ai
perdu alors je compte sur vous pour me
le rappeler fin d'année tiens gros tu as
dit ça est-ce que c'est vrai ce que
c'est faux on verra autre marque que
j'attends vraiment c'est Sony Sony
Xperia one marque 5 Sony c'est une très
belle marque fais les choses un peu
différemment des autres il y a des
choses qui sont des fois un peu
compliqué du point de vue logiciel avec
des soft qui sont un peu compliqué au
niveau de la vidéo la photo ça c'est un
peu amélioré mais il y en a toujours un
peu trop au niveau de la vidéo sur les
faire de la vidéo vous avez le choix
entre trois logiciels c'est un bordel
absolu alors vous pouvez faire tout ce
que vous voulez on peut faire plein de
choses mais pour le novice on s'y perd
un peu alors c'est pas forcément la
cible mais bon donc je vais voir ce
qu'ils vont sortir cette année avec
l'expéria One max 5 autre marque à
suivre également en 2023 ça va être
Huawei Huawei un peu dans le mal quand
même au niveau des smartphones vous le
savez un fatalement ils ont perdu un
service Google il y a un petit moment
2018 même si le travail énormément à
proposer plein de choses ils ont dit
qu'aujourd'hui les smartphones étaient
plus leur priorité alors pour autant ils
ont pas dit qu'ils arrêtaient d'ailleurs
je vais vous parler du maïs 50 très
bientôt d'ailleurs je sais pas moi je
suis dans cette vidéo si je vous aurais
déjà parlé bref on en parle c'est une
très jolie marque qui est très forte qui
s'est bien fabriqué des produits qui a
très belle finition qui est très premium
maintenant est-ce que ça va continuer
pour eux l'aventure du smartphone ou si
oui de quelle manière en 2023 ça c'est
aussi des gros questionnements et puis
après il y a toutes les autres marques à
suivre innovation qu'on a pas forcément
ici qui sont en Asie je pense à du bien
je pense à Red Magic je pense à eu les
folle vous voyez j'ai toujours un peu en
train de suivre l'actu de ces produits
là donc je récupère je déteste des fois
j'en parle des fois j'en parle pas parce
que ça me paraît pas toujours pertinent
des fois ça donc d'ailleurs on en
parlera celui-là là celui-là le Power
Armor 8 800 power Armor 8 ou 18 ans
c'est lui parce qu'ils ont des
références ah non power Armor 18t
excusez-moi 18 t donc ça je vous offre
un petit truc on en reparlera sur
YouTube sur Tik Tok sur insta donc
pensez à vous abonner aussi un peu
partout parce que des fois les contenus
sont pas que ici donc ça ça va être cool
donc vous voyez il y a plein de choses
qui qui vont arriver en 2023 j'ai hâte
de découvrir tout ça donc bon d'ici là
prenez du temps pour vous passer du
temps en famille bonne fête soyez
heureux vive la vie vive l'amour et à
bientôt j'embrasse bisous à bientôt Ciao
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]